first tonight an important update on
Republican Pennsylvania Senate candidate
Kathy Barnett now in the last week out
of nowhere she surged into second place
in the polls and Pennsylvania's very
crowded Republican Senate primary
currently the candidate I endorse and
president Trump endorse Dr Amendment Oz
is holding on to the number one spot but
it's easy to see why Kathy Barnett is
picking up steam and connecting with
voters we've had her on this program in
the past I've had her on my radio show
she's a very impressive person an
incredible life story but because she
was polling so so low just until the
last week or so unfortunately Kathy
Barnett has not gone any kind of
vigorous rigorous vetting that is now
proving to be a massive problem in this
race here's why in 2020 she was not a
serious candidate in her Congressional
race she lost to a pretty weak Democrat
by 19 points and now we are uncovering
many trouble doubling comments and
tweets that would very likely cause her
to lose badly in a general election this
is a very important state there are so
many questions she has never answered
many tweets that likely render her
unelectable in Pennsylvania now this is
a must-hold senate seat if Republicans
have any chance of taking over the U.S
Senate in the midterms this is a Tipping
Point inflection moment for this country
every one of these races matter let me
be clear just because I and many others
find her unelectable doesn't mean I want
Kathy Barnett canceled that's what the
left does most of these problematic
comments and tweets are fairly recent
meaning it wasn't done when she was in
her 20s her 30s these are controversial
extremely controversial comments said
over and over and over again so I've got
to conclude these are are her heartfelt
beliefs Republican voters in
Pennsylvania and around the country you
need to know the call old hard truth let
me put it very simply here I don't see
any scenario where Kathy Barnett can win
a general election in Pennsylvania let
me get specific why first in recent
years she engaged repeatedly in some
pretty disturbing very controversial
rhetoric surrounding gays and lesbians
and Muslims and she makes no distinction
for example between Islam and radical
Islam on to actually cancel a whole
religion on Twitter she asked her
followers to pray for her because quote
she was about to board the plane to
California and quote there was a
homosexual female on the flight in 2015
she tweeted quote Obama did what he does
best shoving his homosexual agenda down
everyone's throats and paraded a slew of
quote gay people before the pope
whatever that means she also heavily
insinuated Obama was a horrible gay
Muslim Obama is horrible on all measures
he loves all things that are homosexual
and supports all things that are Muslim
also on Twitter Barnett seemingly called
for Islam to be banned in the United
States uh that in other words would
eliminate the First Amendment to our U.S
Constitution she also posted this
disturbing image politicizing 9 11
showing an apparent terrorist standing
over the rubble on Ground Zero holding a
sign that reads vote Democratic now we
need your help to kill you there's
certainly A Better Way perhaps of
expressing a view that Democrats might
be weak on National Security don't you
think and meanwhile she also compared
Islam to Nazism told her followers that
it was her right to discriminate against
Muslims and during a lengthy video
posted to her YouTube page she referred
to all of Liz's law Islam as depraved
and evil take a look for yourself
there are a lot of truisms I can talk
about in regards to Islam I spent a
number of years studying it and reading
the Quran talking to Muslims to just to
get an understanding because it is
the mindset of a Muslim is very
different from the mindset of Americans
and that's the reason why we cannot
fully understand the level the depth of
the depravity the depth of the evil
because it's just not a part of the
American fabric for the most part
look she's entitled to her opinions I
believe in freedom of speech but
trashing an entire religion uh I don't
think that's going to get anybody
elected to any office any place anywhere
and it will undoubtedly hurt her in a
Statewide election perhaps this is the
reason why she lost so badly in 2020.
now we on the show were very outspoken
we condemn radical islamists we we don't
attack good people of varying face and
there are good people in every faith I
was raised Catholic but I'm very
critical of the Catholic church because
of the corruption that took place uh I
don't know where she stands on Islam now
but so far she has not addressed any of
these comments nobody's even asked her
now whoever she apparently changed her
opinion about Barack Obama take a look
at this
bitter clingers remember when Barack
Obama called us bitter saying in
Pennsylvania we cling to guns or
religion or dislike people who aren't
like us remember how that made you feel
one candidate for Senate doesn't care in
fact Kathy Barnett wants to build a
statue of Barack Obama right next to the
one of Abraham Lincoln on Capitol Hill
in Washington Kathy Barnett woke
Republican out of touch with
Pennsylvania
I don't know a single conservative not
one I don't know a single Republican not
one that would ever want to put a statue
of Barack Obama next to Abraham Lincoln
that doesn't make any sense why would
any Republican or conservative support
that position only she can answer for
herself now of course Barnett also
changed her mind about Donald Trump she
ultimately did get behind him in the
2016 election but before she did Barnett
once even made fun of yours can you
imagine that why are you attacking me I
ended up being right about Donald Trump
and all those guys like Glenn back Ben
Shapiro honestly In fairness to them
they didn't know Donald Trump the way I
did and they all came around eventually
like Kathy did look opinions can change
people evolve that's okay but there are
so many questions so many controversial
statements so many controversial tweets
that Barnett is either unable or
unwilling to answer like why she
initially slated you know was slated to
speak at at a q Anon conspiracy theory
event why is she backed by the Shady
swampy I mean I am done with the Club
for Growth they're giving her now
millions of dollars and I suspect that's
because they want the Trump endorsed
candidate to lose uh and I wonder
because they now need to answer these
questions why they're supporting Kathy
Barnett with all these millions of
dollars and all these extreme statements
and positions Club for Growth needs to
come on the show and answer those
questions and what about all of the
holes in a resume she said she worked
for two major Financial firms but her
campaign won't tell us where she claims
that she once served as an adjunct
professor of corporate finance we can't
find any evidence of that she also
claims to be an army vet but when the
Washington examiner reached out for
proof her campaign refused to provide
any documentation I'm not saying it
didn't happen why not answer and when
the Free Beacon called for a comment on
this issue well her campaign manager
sure hung up on them today like
yesterday we also reached out to her
campaign on a variety of issues but they
refused to answer any of our questions
when we did somebody on my staff got a
hold of her yesterday and asked about
these tweets she basically said she had
no memory of these tweets at all
whatsoever is she claiming that somebody
hacked her Twitter account anyway Kathy
Barnett is running for the U.S Senate in
what has to be described as a purple
State not an easy win for a republican
in a general election the media mob the
Democratic party they will rip her apart
over all of these issues all of these
comments all of these tweets if she is
unable to clear up these issues right
now before the primary it's my
prediction and I don't think it's a
tough one to make she will be utterly
destroyed in a general election like she
was in 2020. president Trump weighed in
today Kathy Barnett will never be able
to win the Jeff general election against
the radical left Democrats she has many
things in her past which have not been
properly explained or vetted hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else